un auto recorre una curva circular de
radio r con una rapidez lineal v en otra
curva que tiene el mismo radio el auto
viaja con una rapidez lineal un tercio
de v como cambia la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta del auto después
de que disminuye en la rapidez lineal
pausa en el vídeo y tratan de resolver
esto por su cuenta y les daré una pista
sabemos que en general la aceleración
centrípeta es igual a la magnitud de la
velocidad lineal al cuadrado dividida
entre el radio de la curva resolvamos
esto juntos pensemos en la primera curva
la aceleración centrípeta para esta
primera curva es igual a su rapidez v al
cuadrado entre el radio de la curva que
es r con esto calculamos la magnitud de
la aceleración centrípeta de la primera
curva y cómo calculamos la aceleración
centrípeta de la segunda curva va a ser
igual a su rapidez lineal que nos dicen
es un tercio de v elevado al cuadrado
esto dividido entre el radio de la
segunda curva que es igual al radio de
la primera
simplifiquemos esto un poco un tercio de
v al cuadrado es 1 entre 9 por v al
cuadrado entre r también lo podemos
reescribir como 1 entre 9 por v al
cuadrado entre r y la razón por la que
escribí esto en este otro color es
porque es igual a la aceleración
centrípeta de la primera curva esto es
igual a 1 entre 9 por la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta de la primera
curva así que cómo cambia la magnitud de
la aceleración centrípeta del auto
después de que disminuye la rapidez
lineal disminuye por un factor de 9
también podemos decir que se multiplica
por un factor de 1 entre 9 resolvamos
otro ejemplo un papá hace girar a su
hija en un círculo con radio r y con
rapidez angular 'omega' después el papá
extiende sus brazos y hace girar a su
hija en un círculo de radio 2 r con la
misma rapidez angular cómo cambia la
magnitud de la aceleración centrípeta de
la hija cuando el papá extiende sus
brazos de nuevo los invito a que pausa
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta la idea clave aquí es que la
magnitud de la aceleración centrípeta es
igual a r por la rapidez angular al
cuadrado así que la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta inicial es igual
a un mega que es lo que nos dice el
enunciado que es su rapidez angular y
nos dicen que el radio es r así que esto
es igual a r por mega al cuadrado cuando
el papá extiende los brazos tenemos la
aceleración centrípeta final
el enunciado nos dice que ahora el radio
del círculo es 2 r y nos dice que tiene
la misma rapidez angular así que esto es
igual a 2 por r por omega al cuadrado
esta parte de r por mega al cuadrado es
igual a la aceleración centrípeta
inicial así que la magnitud de la
aceleración sentí que está se incrementa
por un factor de 2 lo escribimos con
esto terminamos